- [Instructor] We're told that
each rectangle is a whole.
So this is a whole right over there,
that's one whole, and
so this is two wholes.
Which expressions describe the
shaded part of the picture?
And they've shaded in everything,
and they say choose two answers.
So pause this video and see
if you can answer that before
we work on this together.
So before I even look at the choices,
there's different ways
I could represent this.
I have, I've already talked about
that if each of these
rectangles is a whole,
we have two of 'em, so I
could say this is two wholes.
That's one way to represent it.
Another way to represent it is,
let's see each of the wholes is divided
into two equal sections so this
is a half right over there
and this is another half.
This is a half and this is another half.
So total shaded in we have one,
two, three, four halves shaded in.
So we could also represent
it as four halves.
Or instead of writing half out like that,
you could also represent
a half like that 1/2,
that's another 1/2, that's
another 1/2, that's another 1/2.
And how many of these halves do we have,
we have one, two, three, four.
So how can we write four halves,
well you can write it as 4/2.
So which expressions describe
the shaded part of the picture?
Well it's definitely not just one whole,
we have two wholes here
so I'll rule that one out.
4/2, yep we already
thought about that one.
Four halves, yeah we thought
about that one as well so we're done.